hello everyone how's everybody doing
hope you're doing fine and this is
rational science directly from frankfurt
germany
okay we're a few hours ahead of us where
we have most of the people watching
uh so we're in the first world you're in
the second world
okay today we're going to be dealing
with a very very complex
figure probably the most complex figure
you can imagine
the square before we can get to uh the
square let me tie a couple of blue
scenes
on extinction we had that subject the
other day
and just for those who are not familiar
with this site let me just briefly say
that i have a theory of extinction
mass extinction says that all mass
extinctions
uh happen because food ran out
okay after millions of years
uh the plants uh their
popular population pyramid overturned
okay and those who get stuck
at the end of that process suffering
what is known as a mass extinction all
those animals that are caught in that
situation
by that time all these animals have
grown in size and in numbers
just when the plants are coming down
these guys are going up
and where they meet that's known as a
mass extinction
okay and it happens on land sea and air
and
it is discriminatory in other words
it is selective one
food pyramid dies the other one
continues as if nothing
okay so that's the argument and i'm
saying that's going to happen
to man as well man cannot avoid it no
matter how intelligent he is no matter
what technology
invents it doesn't matter man cannot
avoid that same process
and in our case we make our own food
we unlike the animals that go out and
hunt or eat whatever they find out there
we used to be like that a few thousand
years ago
now we produce our food but that doesn't
change anything
absolutely anything because right now we
produce food because we created a system
called money okay without going into too
much detail
it's called money we produce and
distribute
thanks to money if money disappears
no one produces or distributes food
billions of people die in a matter of
weeks
okay and uh why will
money disappear well because our
economic system
cannot grow forever that in a nutshell
is the theory
there's more details you can find in
some of the other videos
and i try to uh fit
to put in some details here and there
whenever the uh
time allows whenever the questions come
up you know and so
i i try to explain in more detail as
time goes by right now i just want
people to understand the overall theory
money disappears
money disappears when it does not if but
when it does
what happens next what disappears is
food and when food disappears humans
disappear
and it turns out that's the same thing
that killed all animals in the past
they died when food disappeared not
because an asteroid struck
not because a volcano struck not because
there was a supernova
like all these bean brains so-called
scientists
paleontologists say no they never
discovered that
it's a natural process uh human
extinction
uh was programmed by mother nature when
she
spawned us okay and i had a couple
questions on that a couple uh statements
and you know i don't really like to
answer questions unless people address
what i call extinction 101 which is mass
extinction
before they tackle human extinction
everybody's an expert in human
extinction we all know
how man is not going to die that's
essentially
the argument all these people make and
no one could tell me
not only how man is going to die in a
foolproof
way but you know it's be nice if you
start
at mass extinction tell me how a mass
extinction occurs
okay if you can't tell me that you know
you shouldn't even bother about man
okay because you don't know anything
about extinction
and the issue is extinction it's not
economics not politics
it's extinction and economics plays a
role in that because
all animals manage one
and one only i guess the main one the
main
uh resource which is food okay
okay so one fellow says i like this one
says there may be a mass extinction but
i think it will be man-made
okay you think the population is much
too big and will eventually destroy the
world
like a virus you have the vaccine though
you can stop growing food on your land
or use engineered seeds which in a few
years will stop to grow
okay that can kill most of people on the
planet but not all of them
well this gentleman is missing among
other things so many
errors here but what he's missing is
that you know
some people will survive the mass
extinction that's
approaching okay some people always
survive at the end of the line
so the problem is they will not
reproduce okay they will not reproduce
they will not restart
the human race like adam and eve because
our genetic diversity
has disappeared we have no genetic
diversity today
okay so even if they do have kids we're
assuming i don't think they would but
assuming they would
be brave enough to have some kids uh
two or three generations later all gone
okay
all you'll have is optus and
kids with six fingers and so on you know
there's no future
after that okay so it is for all
practical purposes the end of man
even though you know if you survive
pockets here and there okay
okay another fella again they get into
politics
this is not about politics this is about
extinction so
china respects money the west is mired
in a
uh in a major marxist collapse
and marxist uh hate capital china is
more capitalistic than the west and his
marxist in name only
what are you gonna answer i mean poor
guy he's uh
stuck in in this world of politics
and that's all he likes to talk about i
guess you know
lots of people like i mean politics is
the
number one topic out there people like
to talk about politics
women probably talk about cosmetics and
how you look and men talk about politics
nothing has changed in the last 5 000
years
how many people talk about science how
many people talk about a mass extinction
and understand it and research it and
dig deep uh in the uh literature to
figure out you know what could have
happened to those animals
you can count them with the fingers of
one hand okay
okay uh another fella says here
says the only one who addressed the
extinction 101 to some degree
says 65 million years ago the major
continents
were separated there were no land
bridges between the northern southern
hemispheres
if super volcanoes shroud the sun for
one plus years
in whichever hemisphere they occur they
cause
mass starvation
given there was no land bridge 65
million years ago this was not possible
so successive bulk super volcanoes might
extinguish
all large land-based creatures across
both hemispheres
yeah all these people think in
catastrophes
and that's why they never get it right
they think something happened now it was
abrupt
you know the volcanoes cannot explain
what happened to the mosasaurs these
were
reptiles that lived in the seas okay
and to what they ate which were the
ammonites
which uh also disappeared and uh
they disappeared and they ate something
else that disappeared were which were
the for a minifi
the plankton out there you know dianams
and uh
um and for aminifera
all these uh uh tiny animals they
they're the bottom of the food chain
that's what disappeared
so you gotta explain why the how the
volcano
affected the uh the
uh you know plankton that's what you
gotta explain
yeah it's easy to say yeah volcano
killed the dinosaur yeah great
i mean yeah and this is what you gotta
explain really here's here's the graph
okay
anyone who explained that gets a beer
from me okay if you can figure it out
okay here it is
this is the cretaceous terrestrial
revolution took four years to build that
graph
they studied it for a long time they
collected all as much data as they could
and they built this graph what does this
graph show it shows how
plants disappeared okay so what happened
around the middle you could say the
middle of that
cretaceous of that whole period from 145
to 65 million years ago
well what happened is that the
angiosperms crowded out
on the planet all other species
and dinosaurs did not eat angiosperms
even though you'll find a couple papers
out there that argue for that
i think these people have no clue okay
and just burns disappeared i'm sorry
conifers disappeared and what the
angiosperms did they crowded out the
especially the gymnosperms
okay cycads ferns uh also firms
disappeared as well
ferns had disappeared when the conifers
kicked them out
you know ferns ferns were the uh
flora of both the uh permian
and the um triassic then what came in
were the cycads
and the cycad likes you know williams
sonyas and so on
and they kicked out the ferns and what
took over the land were the
uh you know with these new types of
plants which were a type of conifer
and then eventually those conifers
disappeared because they were pushed out
by the angiosperms
and if you look around today you won't
find too many ferns and you won't find
too many conifers of any kind what you
will find
is angiosperms flowering plants
that's what mammals eat mammals don't
eat ferns
mammals don't eat conifers in general
maybe
you'll find some exception here and
there uh
some animal they got used to in general
mammals don't eat that kind of stuff and
so
it's very simple you know uh the permian
and the triassic were the
uh years of the seed ferns especially
the ferns in general but seed ferns
especially
uh then the jurassic and try and uh
cretaceous were the era of the conifers
and today we have the era of the
angiosperms
of the flowering plants so how did
animals die
well apparently their food sources
disappeared
very simple okay except for a
paleontologist
paleontologists think that their job is
to go out there and find
bones dust them up a little bit give
them a fancy name
set them up in a museum and charge
entrance fees
that's what they think a paleontologist
is now that's a
stamp collector okay that's what it's
called
a paleontologist is a necrologist he's a
medical examiner he's a detective he has
to tell me
how the crime was committed that's where
he has to break his brain
but you know to collect evidence and
just bring it in and say well i
collected all these bones
for the court that's not a
paleontologist
now you have to explain to the jury what
you got out of that
what conclusions you came out with and
that's the problem we've had in the last
200 years since paleontology has been
around
not one paleontologist can explain to
you a mass extinction
not one paleontologist can explain to
you how
a background extinction occurs when a
single
species disappears and of course all the
recent one for the last uh maybe two
thousand ten thousand years
or even more uh they say it's man men
kill them all
we're such mean creatures we kill we
make all these species disappear we kill
the dodo we kill the passenger pigeon we
kill the
uh great hawk and so on we killed all
these the
the uh what is it the tasmanian tiger we
killed them all
we're such murderers yeah
how come we ended up with only one uh
tasmanian
devil tasmania not a tiger sorry
that's what you got explained how that
animal whittled down to
nothing we might have killed the last
one yeah that doesn't mean that's caused
the extinction of these
animals okay so uh
and there's one more uh yeah
one fellow says
i can get this thing up there oh come on
give me a second here there we go
uh says extinction theory bill there is
a video blah blah blah
gives the link where it is supporting
your proposal
absolutely not there is no one that
supports my proposal out there first of
all because no one knows about it the
only way they're going to find out
coming to this channel but when you look
at all these people all these people who
talk about
the possibility of extinction you know
their arguments have nothing to do with
mine okay
first of all none of them and second
none of them are foolproof
okay so all these all these people talk
about extinction they talk about climate
change
they talk about you know if we don't do
this we'll become extinct
they're just giving you a recommendation
they don't know how man will
become extinct no matter what
guaranteed no one says that no one says
that it's guaranteed that man will
become extinct
and i'm telling you it's guaranteed
because the economy
will collapse and when not if but when
it collapses
no one will produce food billions will
die
you don't eat you die it's very simple
and that's how eight
you can kill eight billion people if
they don't eat four weeks
it doesn't matter you know they're gonna
die and so
uh i do have a foolproof mechanism i say
it's guaranteed and it will happen it
will happen very soon
that's very different than what all
these people say these people have no
clue about extinction whatsoever
most of them talk about climate change
and uh we got to do something about the
climate
climate has nothing at all to do with
extinction
the only the only role of climate change
is
when when uh the new uh
species of animals radiate once the big
guys are gone when the dinosaurs were
gone
all these tiny mammals they could expand
why because the big guys were out of the
way
that's one issue the other one is that
their sources of food were expanding as
well the
the angiosperms were displacing the
conifers that's why they could expand as
well
and of course all these animals you know
they each one squatted some niche here
and there and they grew into the animals
we have today
and we're one of them even though some
people don't think that humans are
animals they they think we're not
because they say they have a brain and
that makes me
very suspicious whether you really have
a brain or not you know i don't know
about that
okay let's get to the subject matter
today of today which is the square
and we all know what a square is i mean
do we need to spend
a lecture on the square
i mean you know the other day we did
circles and we did semi-circle
semi-circles
and today we're going to do the squares
don't you have anything better to talk
about bill
well i would if it were that someone out
there can tell me what a square
is but it turns out no one knows what a
square is just like no one knows what a
circle
is okay that's gonna be my argument
today uh
if you know what a square is please
please
show me okay i'm gonna show you today
that
no one in geometry especially those who
teach
geometry no one has any idea what a
circle is no one knows what
or understands what a semi-circle is and
no one
no one absolutely no one has any idea
what a square is
after three thousand years that they
cannot tell you what a square is
in fact uh you'll find a lot of these
so-called chaometers
and the first thing they'll say is
though we don't know what a point is
because it's an
undefined uh figure i guess
whatever they call it and they say it's
an undefined
term and the line is undefined
and so they have all these undefined
terms and and
it turns out those terms form the
foundations of geometry it's got to give
you a clue that these fellows
they have no idea whatsoever what
any of the higher uh figures are like
you know squares and cubes and so on i
mean if they don't know what a point is
and a
point underlies their other figures what
can they tell us about the higher
figures
okay so that's more or less going to be
the argument today but uh i'll be more
specific
let's get started here here we have
is that a square i mean if if i ask you
please draw a square or i ask a
kindergartner because you might be
biased already but
let's ask a kindergartner someone in
elementary school
a kid that's anywhere from five to ten
years old okay draw me a square what
would you draw or i
show them a square a circle and a
triangle for example and i say
which one is the square do you think he
would be able to identify the square
i think he would because he's unbiased
he's been taught yeah that's the square
the one over there
and that's what i'm showing there that's
the square and that's what a lot of
people would draw and that's what a lot
of people would point to
okay they say yeah that's the square
uh no that's not the square
so if this is what you think is a square
you never learn geometry okay you have
no clue whatsoever
about geometry if you think that's a
square
okay and uh first thing i would have to
ask is whether a square is a geometric
figure okay
and then question is what is a figure
because it turns out that we have
wolfram
uh you know they say they're the most
popular the most
advanced uh site on the internet
regarding
mathematics and and
you ask them what is a circle and they
say what's a figure that blah blah blah
blah blah
and you say okay what is a figure and
they don't have a definition for the
word figure so their whole
argument falls apart because the key
word
is missing in their entire website you
don't have a definition
for the word figure okay fortunately
mr euclid did a little better job he
tried to define figure
whether he did it right or not you know
at least he tried okay
so in that sense i have to give credit
to mr euclid
okay so uh why don't we start at the
beginning
um we're doing physics here this is what
physics is about what this channel is
about it's about
physics and the question is does physics
require an object can you do physics
without
an object if you raise all matter in the
universe
can you do what's happening what's going
on what's moving
what are you staring at what tests are
you gonna run what are you gonna juggle
what are you gonna study if there's
nothing there
so i'm saying that the first rule the
first law
the first principle of physics is
you cannot do physics without an object
you need an object to do physics
okay you can't move concepts around you
can't move love over here and energy
over there you have to use
a physical object so we need to know
what an object is an
object is a synonym of that word there
figure
okay so here goes these are the
questions for anyone who wants to be a
physicist
if you if you elude these questions
you're just hiding your religion you
have no idea what physics is about
so these are the questions a physicist
must
answer and cannot avoid okay
first one are topics such as what causes
gravity what causes magnetism are those
a part of physics
are those questions of physics those
questions that a physicist must answer
what causes gravity you know here here
we have a pen yeah
and we let it go and it falls to the
floor
in this case the table right falls
always downward never falls upwards i
don't know why you know
uh do we have to answer those questions
are those questions of physics are those
questions
that a physicist is interested in
answering that's the first issue
do we explain mechanisms in physics here
we have a mechanism okay
we let go the pen it falls
there's some kind of mechanism going on
okay something's happening there
okay and so do we explain mechanisms in
physics
is that part of the subject matter of
physics
yes or no these are all yes or no
questions by the way okay
or are such issues subject matter or
philosophy
is this a question philosophy of what
causes
this to fall to the floor is this
philosophy uh
i always use my two little magnets there
okay
uh this is a mechanism something's going
on here
it's already pulling on my fingers you
know it's it's already
you can draw it you can do it at your
own leisure at home
take two magnets you'll see you you know
one pulls on the other
uh you know is the mechanism is that an
issue
of physics or is this an issue of
philosophy
or religion or some other is this an
issue of
psychology consciousness i don't know
uh so it's a yes or no question is it a
issue of philosophy
can we explain a mechanism without
objects
if i don't have an object can i explain
for example here uh
let me give you an example
okay here's a ball and it's tied to a
little string okay a little elastic
string okay
so i'm doing like that if if if i had to
explain
why the ball goes up and down could i
explain it to you
without referring to this
uh elastic
band i mean can i explain this
phenomenon that the ball is bouncing up
and down
i'm talking about an explanation not
describing i don't want to describe i
don't want to know
how fast it goes i i want to know why it
goes
up and down and everybody would say well
you're pulling on the
on the string okay that's fine
but could you do it without referencing
the string could you explain the
mechanism
why that ball goes up and down without
talking about the string
and that's what i'm saying can you
explain a mechanism without using an
object
in fact if i got rid of the ball as well
you know there would be nothing to
explain
there would be nothing going up and down
so here are the issues
uh those four questions they're yes or
no
you can't miss any of them if you miss
answering those in a rational way
uh you're first an irrational individual
and second
uh you're hiding something you're hiding
behind a you're shielding yourself
behind some kind of religion
something you have deep inside you so
this is a good
way of psychoanalyzing yourself uh
you're hiding
you're hiding something you're you're
not willing to answer those questions
because they destroy your religion
destroy your
your way of thinking uh how you grew up
how you were educated
that's why you would not you would try
to avoid these questions that's the only
reason you would try to avoid them
okay okay
so you get to answer those questions if
you want to be a physicist
otherwise you're just going to be doing
religion
okay uh here's uh for another for
instance here you see a pulley
okay pulling out a box okay
there's a rope tied around the pulley
tied to the box and pulls it up
okay we need to to explain that you need
to have the
rope you need to have the pulling you
have to have the box
you have to point to all these objects
okay these
figures these things and
uh and then you can explain it how the
box goes up
now what what if i showed this
the box just goes up
and i say well where's the box going up
well what would you say there are
spirits uh magic black magic
what are you gonna uh introduce here to
explain why that box goes up
okay that's what you gotta explain you
gotta explain why that box goes up
you're gonna need to put in
some physical objects you're not gonna
have to identify the objects
okay otherwise you're doing uh religion
you're introducing spirits black magic
god who knows
okay so if we need an object to do
physics
what the hell is an object what is this
thing called
figure okay see if i can get this thing
up there
give me a second here okay so uh
in uh physics we define an object as
that which has shape
and what do we mean by that well it
means that it's the only universal
property of
all objects all objects have shape there
is not
a single object that does not have shape
and if you can think of one
uh please draw it
okay so if you know of an object that
doesn't have shape please draw it
okay it's got to be standalone got to be
independent what do we mean by that well
you should be able to point to it it
should be the only object in the
universe
when you present it okay it's like
there's nothing else in the universe
we gotta have like in that case you see
an example there you see that
uh whatchamacallit and that's an object
why is it an object because it has shape
the black stuff
is just space that's the background that
gives
you know contour to the object if
that black background wasn't there uh
the object would be infinite and then
therefore it wouldn't be an object
because an object is that which has
shape
so it has to have some contour okay now
that black stuff is that
does that have shape and the answer is
no the black stuff is
nothing that which doesn't have shape so
we have shape within
that which doesn't have shape and that
which doesn't have shape
is put there just so that you can
identify the shape
okay so that's an object for the
purposes of physics
as you can see it's standing alone
there's no other object nearby we don't
need any other object to
put it to call that one x object called
x okay it's an independent object uh
unlike a magnetic field which depends on
the magnet
okay this one doesn't depend on anything
okay it stands alone
okay so in that sense it's a soul object
in the universe we should be able to put
it out there in the middle of space all
by itself
okay uh or you should be able to point
to it
okay it's gotta be motionless
uh no object involves motion
and please keep that in mind for what
we're going to be talking about today
which is the
square okay i'll talk a little bit about
the circle as well
but important motionless timeless what
do we mean by that well it occupies a
single frame in the universal movie
okay if it occupies two frames it's not
an object
it's an object in motion and an object
in motion
is not an object for example plasma is
not an object it's not a standalone
object plasma means ionized gas
it's a concept and a wave
you know the transverse wave not an
object okay
wave is something in motion and so on
down the line so you you can't use these
words energy another one you know mass
all those are concepts dynamic concepts
not one of them is a standalone object
because you need two frames in the movie
to talk about
energy mass uh ether
any of these okay you need two frames in
a movie
okay um an object is not a concept
and a lot of people confuse them they
think objects are concepts
we had one fellow who said that a
two-dimensional
object is a concept so we have
two-dimensional concepts
okay um and object
and concept are the only two categories
of every word in the dictionary
every word in the dictionary has to fall
under concept or object there is
no third category okay
and if you have a different category
you need to put that in there and defend
it not only just put it but
defend it and i'm going to show you that
it's one of the two if it has shape it's
going to be an object if it doesn't have
shape it's got to be a concept
there is no third possibility god either
has shape
or god doesn't have shape god cannot be
both
have shape and not have shape okay he
can't be both an
object and a concept simultaneously
so you got to decide who you who you're
praying to whether
the object called god the guy with a
magic wand i guess
and or the concept called love or spirit
or or or knowledge or intelligence or
whatever
okay and uh we should not confuse the
word object with the word exist
which is where 99 of the problems are
out there people confuse the word object
with the word exist
they think that these two words are
synonyms okay and i'll be talking about
that a little bit today
what's my conclusion the definition of
the word object destroys
all religions once you define the word
object
no religion can stand in place
okay no one can defend their religion
once you define the word object and all
they can do is run away with their tails
between their legs not define the word
object saying they will not play that
game etc etc etc
that's all they can do they cannot come
in there and define the word
object in any other way and so you know
that's the trick you gotta
define the word object don't tell me
what an object
ain't tell me what an object is okay if
you can't define the word object you
have no standing especially in physics
because physics cannot be done without
an object it's a mandatory word
the first word a physicist must define
okay so i hope that's clear okay let's
move on here
oh
gotta get these from all the way from
the bottom okay okay so
is a circle or a square right either one
doesn't matter
a figure is it an object is it a thing
okay well according to the definition of
object it is because it has shape
and so what we have to do is go to
beginning and we go to euclid from his
book elements this is how
this whole thing started okay and what
did
you could do well he had a few
definitions and especially in his book
one where he starts all this stuff he
tries to make sense
of geometry the first thing he defines
or one of the first things he defines is
a boundary he says a boundary is that
which is an
extremity of anything okay i guess he's
referring to the perimeter the
outside edge any way you want to
describe that okay
so i think of boundary we understand
what he's trying to say there i think
okay i don't know if anyone has any uh
objection to his notion his general
notion what a boundary is
what is a figure figure is that which is
contained by any boundary or boundaries
okay i say it differently i say it's
that which has shape but
uh it's close enough i have
no objection to uh euclid's notion of
figure
the only objection i have is that he
never used that definition
that's the problem with his definition
neither him nor anyone who came after
ever used that definition
and even worse they never realized how
important that definition was
you can't do physics without an object
meaning can't do physics without a
figure
and it turns out that everybody does
physics without a figure because they
never define what a figure is they don't
know what a figure is and they never did
physics okay that's where the problem is
okay
okay so he says what is a circle a
circle is a plane figure
blah blah blah blah blah okay so it's a
figure
it's a thing it's got a boundary okay
and uh he said in definition 14 he says
that which is contained by
so he's saying that it's the inside
which is a circle okay very
important uh distinction to what we have
today
um what is a square well of
quadrilateral
figures a square is that which is both
equilibrium
and right angle in other words it's got
four sides that's what
uh quadrilateral means and it's got four
angles
okay four right angles okay so uh
so is is that what a square is
okay or is this a description of a
square
i mean i need to know what a square is
before you can describe it what
what euclid did was something totally
irrational
he's trying to define an object
you can't define an object you don't
define
the word man you point to a man
you don't define the word table you
point to a table
then you can describe it and say it's
got four legs you know a
board you know you can go out there and
describe it later on
first you gotta point and name it
because you need to teach
the et your language you get he's got to
know what the
word table refers to and you cannot just
talk in
general term well it's got four legs and
a top and
whatever and a board no you got to point
to it then he knows what the word table
refers to now you can do the all the
descriptions you want and what euclid
did here
he did not define he did not point he
did not draw it he
just tried to define it and that's a big
error it means the geometers of grease
had no clue whatsoever what geometry was
about because if it is about
figures if it's about shapes what he
said figure there okay
contained by what a boundary
then all he had to do was draw it into
that and he was done he said this is
this is a circle this is a square okay
and no one has ever done that that's the
interesting part no one has done that
okay so do circles squares belong to
category of geometric figures known as
planes
well let's see what euclid has to say
about he says in definition five a
surface is that which has
length and breath only well i don't know
if
it was euclid or his translator but
breath is not a dimension
breath is a vector okay breath has to do
with
motion you know sideways motion
death is inward motion and height
is upward motion okay and uh
no geometry ever figure that out those
are vectors you cannot confuse you can't
mix uh the word length
uh with the word breath because you're
talking about two different things
now whether that was euclid's fault or
his translator i don't know but someone
aired grossly and this error is repeated
generation by generation
group generation okay okay
do circles and squares have two
dimensions whether surfaces that which
has
length and breadth uh the edges of a
surface
are wet lines very important point today
what are the edges of a surface
they are lines okay
and keep that in mind that's very
important point lines i'm going to
focus on lines lines lines until it
hurts
today okay a plain surface is a surface
which lies evenly
with the straight wet lines on itself
so we're going to be talking about lines
okay and then again i do concepts have
dimensions
again we have the spell who says that a
two-dimensional object is a concept
so we have two dimensional concepts
today
nice here my dear soul
okay let's continue let's roll on here
and uh what is a circle square contoured
by
well i think it's going to be by a line
i think
okay a plane surface is a surface which
lies evenly with a straight what lines
on itself
okay so uh you could define
uh this plane whatever plane it is
as uh something dealing with lines okay
and what is the in definition 15 he says
a circle is a plane figure contained by
one what line okay
and the question is whether that is a
line there that you see there you know i
put a bunch of dots is that a line
well let's find out uh how about a
square
uh definition 19 says rectilinear
figures are those which are contained by
what
straight lines quadrilateral those
contained by
four lines
definition 22 of quadrilateral figures
as square as that which is
both equilateral and uh
right angled okay so what are we talking
about we're talking about lines
i guess we have to get to the bottom of
what a line is
but uh it turns out that uh you know
line is what made of points
okay here we see it
see if we can find out what this is
about what is a line
line is a is breathless length according
to euclid okay the ends of a line are
what
points and a straight line is a line
which lies evenly with the
what points on itself
and what does the wikipedia say for line
today and
everybody says the same thing so
wikipedia is good enough for this
line the set of what points
the set of points okay so what is a line
it's not a solid line it's a it's a set
of points often described in terms of
what
two points we got that from euclid okay
so what is a line is a bunch of points
whether it's curved or straight
doesn't matter it's a bunch of points
that's what a line is
okay so what is a point i mean if
if a plane is made of lines and a line
is made of points let's get down to the
nitty-gritty let's find out what a point
is okay and so
uh here we see it a point is a primitive
notion
what do they mean by that that they
won't be able to define it
why because you don't define figures
assuming the point is a figure and
that's what we're going to get to
uh is a primitive notion upon which the
geometry is built so geometry is built
on this thing and they can't define it
because it's primitive
primitive means they can't define it
meaning that a point cannot be defined
in terms of previously defined objects
yeah what are you going to define a
point if uh
if it's the building block of all the
others
so he says it's the bottom one so we
can't define that one
yeah you can't define any gm geometric
figure
figures we point to and i'm not sure
what you're going to point to in the
case of
a point because uh euclid says it has
it's that which has no part meaning no
dimensions no size no
volume no nothing a point is zero it's
nothing
that's what a point is and that's what
these people are dealing with the
geometers
okay geometric points do not have any
what length
area volume or any other dimensional
attribute
so what is a point what kind of
geometric what
figure is a point
and maybe that explains why the famous
geometers
and mathematicians of wolfram did not
define the word figure because otherwise
you would say well hold it's contained
within a boundary
uh what is a point contained within if
it's got no volume dimensions
length uh diameter or whatever
yeah we have a problem we got to find
out what this why they have so much
trouble with the word point what's the
what's the deal here okay the concept of
a point oh so
it's a concept i thought it was an
object i thought it was a figure
i thought it was a geometric figure but
it turns out it's a
concept okay so we have another concept
that
this concept is zero dimensional
captures the notion of location
the word point in the religion of
geometry
means location that's what it means it's
not a geometric
figure it's a concept
that they use the word point because
they're going to
represent it with a dot but then they're
going to tell you well forget about the
thought don't
don't think about the dot we're just
gonna
focus on what the dot represents which
is a location where something
it supposedly is well if something is
supposedly
in there like an elephant why don't you
just put the elephant
why do you represent the elephant with a
dot
that is two dimensional at least maybe
three
and then tell me oh forget about the
thought that's not the point the point
is what it represents which is the
location the location of word of the
elephant why did you put the elf
and what they do is they put the center
of mass of the elephant
perhaps you know something like that and
so they said well we take this whole
elephant
we don't care about the elephant we care
about his mass he weighs five tons and
we're gonna put five tons in there
and that's gonna be the point that's
gonna be the number that's gonna be the
dot
that's gonna be the point of geometry
they're not gonna tell you where the
elephant is they're gonna tell you where
the point is
which is what the center of mass of the
elephant okay so this is how it's going
to be working out
and yeah that's what a point looks like
according to their definition
okay and the question is whether
location is a geometric
figure is location a geometric figure
if it's not it doesn't belong to
geometry we have to start with
a geometric figure if it start if we're
going to do geometry
so this is where we have a little bit of
a problem okay
okay and so um here's the line
that people think of they say well it's
a continuous line it's a
made of a single piece solid you know
not in geometry uh geometry uh
looks more like this
is that what it is well it turns out
it's not even that
not even that this is the line of
geometry
that one there okay
so keep in mind this is the line of
geometry let me put it over here
that's what a line is in geometry a
moving point
which is what location yeah the point
occupies the location occupies many
locations
what are we talking about we're talking
about motion because two or more
locations is motion
and so this is the problem here the
problem is that these people are talking
about
geometry figures boundaries
and they don't use any of that at all
not at all
what they want is relations they want to
measure
something and they want to look at
angles and they want to look at speeds
and that kind of thing or
ratios or you know things of that nature
they're not going to look at the
geometry itself they don't care about
objects because no mathematician
ever on planet earth ever cared about
objects
that's why they're the wrong people to
do physics because like i said at the
beginning
you can't do physics without an object
and the first uh
job of a physicist is to define the word
object that's what we're going to be
working with
if you're going to explain the mechanism
like the pulley or
like i said you know the ball here
that's hanging right
more or less like a pulley uh then
you're gonna need objects you don't need
any math at all you don't need any
relations or ratios or anything like
that
all you need to do is identify the
objection tell me what the mechanism is
that's what we want to do in physics we
want to explain gravity
we want to explain magnetism we want to
explain why um
light travels so fast what is light
we want to know what an atom looks like
why it does its quantum jump those are
the question what is electricity those
are the questions of physics
and those are all mechanisms you don't
need any math for any of them
math is not the language of physics
illustration
is the language of physics you have to
illustrate you got to make a movie of
your theory
okay and so if that's the point okay
and uh i'm sorry if that's the line of
the line's just a moving
point then what is the line well a line
is
uh an itinerary a trajectory it's motion
that's what a line is to a geometer and
that's exactly what all these
mathematicians put in their equations
they're not talking about a line they
use the word line you think of
oh yeah a solid line absolutely not
they're talking about an itinerary
that's why they call it one dimensional
because what they're talking about is
not that it has three dimensions
obviously if
anything that in in our macro world that
moves is three dimension
and you say well how can how can uh
a line be one dimensional i can't even
draw that because you can't draw
anything that's one dimensional as soon
as you put that pencil or the chalk
you know on a surface you've got two
dimensions at minimum
so there is no such thing as one
dimensional what are they talking about
they're talking about motion that's why
they use the term one-dimensional
because they're saying it's just
a line they're moving along a line
they're not talking about lines they're
not talking about
uh objects what they're talking about is
motion
and motion is made of locations and
that's what the point is
so we're not talking about geometry at
all we're talking about locations and
we're talking about motion
okay that's what a geometer does
it doesn't deal with uh geometries at
all with figures at all
okay so let's continue here
and so a circle uh we we
start with the circle right a circle is
a simple closed
curve what was a curve well the curve is
made of
points it's a line and a line is made of
points so it doesn't matter if it's
curved or not okay
so it's closed curve that divides the
plane into two regions
an interior and an exterior
i thought the the interior was not part
of the circle
okay in everyday use the term circle may
be used
interchangeably to refer to either the
boundary of the figure
or to the whole figure including its
interior
in strict technical usage oh
we're getting technical here the circuit
is only the boundary and the whole
figure
is called a disk so these people are
saying that the boundary
that the circle is the circumference
bunch of dots
going around they're all discrete dots
they're not connected there's space
between each dot
otherwise we can't talk about a dot or
location because the location of
whatever
has a certain size you could say you
know the size of the thing that occupies
the location
okay so there is no such thing as a
spread out location
the location is here and the location as
they always put it
you they use a uh an ordered pair or a
triple
triplet or whatever okay but yeah it's
made out of points
and those points dots right are
representing location so circumference
is just a bunch of locations and they're
saying that the circle
is a bunch of locations and so the guy
on the right is known as this the guy on
the
left is known as the circumference what
the hell do we need the word
circle for at all we already have the
word for
what they call a circle it's called
circumference and we already have the
word for
disk which is the guy on the right so
what do we need the word circle for
okay and and this is part of the problem
because they jump back and forth they
point to that say well that's a circle
and that's what everybody understands by
a circle but the circle is really the
circumference
so which is it why do we need the word
circle we don't need it in science at
all if if they're going to go back and
forth
and uh it turns out that you know the
circle is more like this
that's a circle because uh
they say it is the curve traced
traced out by a point
that moves in a plane so that its
distance from a given point
is constant so we have the point which
is a location
and the location is moving around they
represent the location with a dot and
they say don't pay attention to the dot
but that's what they're showing in other
words
um the so-called circle is an
orbit that's what it is
it's not a g is that a geometric figure
are you staring at a geometric figure
and i don't mean a blue ball i'm talking
about what the
blue ball is describing is that a circle
but that's what we have as far as
definitions this is strictly from the
definitions
i didn't invent this stuff okay this is
what they say
is a circle so uh yeah we have a little
bit of problem with what all these
people are saying because their
definitions
uh first don't match uh geometry which
is
the figures first and foremost about
figures objects things
and second they're talking about motion
then they're using these words
uh in a very deceptive way okay whether
knowingly or not
they put a dot to represent the location
and they call it a point and so you
don't know if the
point is the dot or the location
and they build the geometric figures
with dots but then they say
well it's just a bunch of locations so
here you have a cube
or or a sphere for that matter and what
you have is
locations and yeah they said between any
two locations you can have another
location
meaning that between any two points you
can have another point
and they do all these fancy things
because they're not talking about points
which what what a normal
sane human being understands by the word
point which is
a dot that's not what it is in geometry
and geometry it's a location in other
words they're not talking about
geometric figures
at all okay let's continue here
here's the square which is the subject
of today
is that the square absolutely not
this is a square
if i need it up here give me a second
this is the square okay that's a square
a square is a dot moving all around
and it's not even a dot it's a location
that's moving from location to location
that's what a square is
okay so if you thought that the square
was the guy on the left well you
didn't understand what they you you
didn't read you have problems with
reading comprehension
okay this is a square square is a bunch
of dots
that go around okay and it's a perimeter
you could say and
best case scenario you i mean you can
draw them all in there and
just make your little square with dots
but
the square above all is not a continuous
figure which is what uh euclid tried to
define at least
he said it's continued these people
don't have that they say it's made of
points
in fact euclid said the same thing for
that matter because he
he built his
planes with dots with lines and when our
lines dots
bunch of dots and whatever the bunch of
dots are a bunch of locations
so we don't have anything in front of us
because there's no physical
entity in front of us there's no object
no
shape no figure all we have in front of
us
are locations and what they do is they
set them in motion
so when you see a location moving from
location to location well that's called
the line
and if it's a curve they call it a
curved line or a curve
and so on so we're talking about motion
of locations
from location to location that's what
geometry is that's what
a square is that's what a circle is okay
semicircles also okay uh what should we
conclude oh no i got uh
another one here just in case okay
you can fill it in leave it there you
know say that's a square
okay that's another version of the
square okay
uh but really you know it's just a
moving location
that's all it is the mathematicians
don't care about figures they
mathematics has no use for figures
mathematics has no use for objects they
can't put the word
dog in an equation they can't put the
word rock in an equation they have to
put the mass of the dog or the
size of the rock or the volume of the
tree they have to put
numbers in there with units so math has
no
use for objects that's why the
mathematicians
are the least skilled people
to do physics they have no clue
whatsoever
how to give a physical interpretation to
anything
in fact they have no problem giving you
an irrational explanation because that's
what their equations tell them
that's their interpretation of their
equation so they don't care about the
physical world
world physics for them is alien
completely alien all they want to do is
equations
and then they give you an irrational
physical interpretation and people think
they're so
smart because they know how to read
those hieroglyphics that's the only
reason
they say oh he knows how to read all
that stuff he must be a genius
now he must be a genius for that which
is more like autism because a guy who
goes into so much detail in mathematics
has a a problem a mental problem really
but then you know that guy is totally
unqualified
to give you a physical interpretation
and that's the status of so-called
mathematical physics today
okay okay um
let me give you a conclusion here
well i've got before before i get to
that let me
show you a few questions that people
raised
this is regarding the circle and it
applies to the square as well
and uh they're important questions these
are questions that people pop up with
you know
when they say well hold it how about the
circle this
how about that and so it's important to
fill in these
blanks okay so let's cover this before i
move to
my summary my conclusions okay this
fellow says the following he says
i don't understand why i can see spaces
in that diagram
labeled circumferences and this which i
showed the other day which is the one on
the bottom
okay so we have circumference we have
this and i'm saying what the hell do we
need the word circle for
if we have a word for circumference
which is what they say the circle is
we have a word for the disc what else is
there so
we don't need the word circle and he
says i can't see why can't
why i can see spaces in that diagram
space
labeled circumference in this anywhere
on that set
where you can see space there should
obviously be another point
no that diagram is a total failure
well uh so what is he saying well he's
saying this
see if i can get this thing up here give
me a second here
this is what he's saying he's saying
what if we uh put dots in there right
he's saying there should be no spaces
because everything should be covered by
dots
whether you took talk about the disc or
the circumference
and the answer is no the answer is that
if you're going to talk about dots okay
if they're discrete dots there's got to
be space all around it sorry
so there's got to be space and you can
put another dot between any two dots
you're still going to have space between
two dots no matter what otherwise you
don't have one dot you have two dots
merged you have a single piece dot
so to speak two dots that merged into
one
and that's not the case because a dot is
a discrete entity
so if you've got that uh you you can put
as many dots as you want between any two
dots you're going to find space anyways
so no you can't fill it with dots
every time you put a dot in there that
dot has to have space
all around it to contour it otherwise
you cannot talk about the word
dot okay and it gets worse when you say
well
i wasn't talking about dots anyways i
was talking about a point and what is
the point well the point is the location
and so what contours a location
space well you know locations don't have
dimensions and you
they're not really objects they're not
figures okay
so uh you can't use the word dot if
you're going to use the word location
if it's a synonym of location so either
you use the dot
and you have space all around it or you
use the word location
in which case you have absolutely
nothing
okay because location is a concept it's
not a figure it doesn't have contour it
doesn't have anything surrounding it
okay so we got to get all these things
in the right context
okay and the fellow keeps going and he
says
he continues he says the following
he says uh here's another word you
should look up continuum
oh my god he touched the raw nerve there
continuum okay well i think the guy
who's got to look up the word is him i
don't think he has the slightest clue
what a continuum
means just like the square people think
a continuum
is a continuum and it's not
in the religion of mathematics in the
religion
of geometry in the religion of
mathematical physics
continuum means discrete means
segmented means made of parts that's
what continuous
means and that's what continuum means
okay
evidence proof let's do it let's provide
evidence in fact someone else uh
doubled up on him said the following
also
my god these poor people what the what
you do not understand about continuous
line
i understand it uh-huh although it is
not used
in geometry oh very interesting that he
said that it's not used at all
why would anybody use invent the word
that he's not going to use and he's
going to say well the line is continuous
but i'm not going to use it at all
okay but he says that it's good that he
says it but he doesn't realize his
contradiction
okay a solid line is different from a
broken line
yeah i know it is i'm just saying that
there is no such thing as a solid line
in all of mathematics in all of
mathematical physics and in all of
geometry
there's no such thing as a solid line
line is made a point the word line means
made of points which are what
locations that's what you don't
understand
okay i understand what continuous means
because i talk about objects
these people have no clue because they
don't talk about objects they're not
talking about
figures they're not talking about
geometries they're talking about
concepts about motion about locations
that's not a geometric figure that's
what you don't understand
okay so keep that in mind since the
circle is an imaginary
figure okay so-called figure made of
locations is that what a circle is made
of
that can only be drawn saying that it is
a
continuous line does not seem
inappropriate or wrong to me
well again because these people don't do
any reading comprehension they just
swallow this stuff and they have no clue
whatsoever what they're saying
okay this is where the problem is they
just
regurgitate what they heard out there
what their teacher taught him or
whatever
okay so let's find out let's provide
some proven evidence that
continuous means segmented men made of
little points uh chopped
pieces that's what continuum means in
religion
of in the religion of mathematical
physics and in
mathematics and in geometry they never
were able to define these word properly
okay here's a here's a continuum
according to math this is the math part
in mathematics in the field in the
mathematical field
of set theory the continuum means what
the real numbers that's what continue
means
what are numbers where well hopefully
they're all discreet because
the five uh comes after four and before
the six so they're all kind of chopped
separately okay so if they're numbers
what kind of continuum is that and then
between any
real number you can fit a decimal point
obviously but even if you talk about
real numbers it's chopped off what do
you
what are you counting you're counting
cheap well hopefully the sheep are
segmented you know they're they're
discrete so
continuum means a whole bunch of sheep
that
you know you count you know one two
three four five six seven so that's a
continuum to a mathematician
uh what's another notion the real line
what is a real line
well it's uh the real numbers again
bunch of numbers that's what continuum
means
uh another one in poinsett topology
okay continuum is what is a non-empty
compact
connected connected metric space so if
it's connected you're connecting two
things
obviously it's not continuum it's
discrete it's segmented it's made of
pieces of parts okay what's a metric
space
in mathematics a metric space is what a
set
together with a metric on the set the
metric is a function that defines a
concept of what
distance distance between what between
any two members of the set
so a continuum means that it's made of a
bunch of
discrete parts that's what continuum
means in mathematics
which are usually called what points
what is a point a location how many
locations are there well depends on how
many
times a kangaroo jumped summary in
mathematics in the religion of
geometry religion
it's irrational continuous means
segmented discrete
made of parts that's what continuum
means
that's why that's what all these people
don't understand they tell me to go look
up the word continuum they should look
it up
okay okay and here we have another
uh evidence proof okay so people
read for a change okay sometimes i try
to chop these things off people get
upset
when i do that i should do that because
people don't know how to read
they don't understand what they're
reading they get they get the
bamboozled by all the wording and they
lose the the
real meaning that's you know
encapsulated in that sentence
a continuum that contains more than what
one point is called a blob
non-degenerate
i think the degenerates are others
mathematicians are degenerate more than
one point that's what continuum means
okay a subset a of a continuum what do
you mean a subset
i thought continuing was made of a
single piece
they say that's a subset is
part of a continuum continuum x is
homogeneous
if for every what two points blah blah
blah blah blah
so we're talking about many points what
our points location so we're talking
about many locations that's what a
continuum
is they're talking about motion
continuous motion if anything okay
really it's not continuous because
continuous is an adjective you cannot
use
adjectives in physics in physics not in
ordinary speech
in physics you cannot use an adjective
qualified motion
these people are qualifying motion with
the word continuous
and then they ended up with this noun
called continuum like they
used the word infinite and then they
ended up with infinity
same thing they turned the adjective
into an adjective into a noun
no it's if it's connected at each point
and and you're talking about
numbers or whatever then you're not
talking about a continuum you're talking
about this
you know segmented you're talking about
many pieces a one-dimensional continuum
is often called a what a curve what is a
curve
a bunch of points that's what uh
what are the points and locations that's
what a curve is they're talking about
motion
so they talk about continuous motion
when in reality it's
incessant motion is the correct word
the rabbit is moving incessantly
then you can use it like that that's the
way
you should use um adverbs for
motion adjectives are for objects to
describe objects
and as long as we keep it there you know
we're okay it's when we start mixing
these things up and use
ordinary speech and bring that into
physics that's when people get lost all
together
again summary and mathematics continuous
equals segmented discrete
made of parts no matter how you twist
and turn it
there's no such thing as continuous
continuum
in mathematics okay um
and here's the physics part we have to
have physics also right
that was the mathematical part this is
the so-called physics
it's called mathematical physics which
ain't physics at all
and here it is uh first one is from
the wikipedia okay a geometric
interpretation of special relativity
that fused time and the three
spatial dimensions they're talking about
space time right of space
into a single four-dimensional what
continuum
okay so we have a four-dimensional
continuum you would think it's a
continuous sheet of some of sorts of
some kind okay
a space-time continuum right
is mathematically defined as a
four-dimensional smooth connected
manifold connected what do you mean
connected
i thought you said smooth made of a
single piece
and no what is a manifold about each
point
event on this manifold blah blah blah
blah blah
so the manifold is made of points and a
point is what is it a
dot is it a location no now an event
is a point in other words the the
so-called location somehow turned into a
happening
an occurrence a something that
motion within a single frame of the
movie of the
universal movie we have motion okay
that's what they're saying is a point a
point is now an event
something that happened a manifold is a
topological
space that locally resembles euclidean
space meaning that if you make it small
enough it's flat okay
near each point okay and what does good
old mr
stephen gawking say say
okay well he says something horrendous
he says space-time this is out of his
book
glossary uh facebook a brief history of
time
the four dimensional space whose points
are events that's what space time is
what is an event a point in space time
specified by its time and place
so we have a problem because these
people uh went further than good old
euclid uh it was
bad enough when they said well the point
is really a location
you know it's uh this abstraction called
the location
and we specify it with an ordered pair
or triplet or whatever okay
and now these people are saying no no no
you're wrong
uh the point is an event it's something
that happened
there we have a movie within a
photograph
within a snapshot
so that's what in a nutshell what
mathematical physics and geometry has
become
okay uh so we look up
uh continuum in the wikipedia and this
is what we find
a continuum is what a body that can be
what
continually sub divided into
infinitesimal
elements that's what a continuum is for
physics according to the religion of
mathematics
okay this is what they came up with
after hundreds and thousands of years of
thinking
of brainstorming whatever and if you
don't believe these folks the people in
the wikipedia here you have good old
aristotle okay
good old area he gave it his best shot
this is where it all came from
see all these people started following
aristotle and they came up with
not the same nonsense or even worse
nonsense than what aristotle came up
with
what does the aristotle say about
continuum he says
this is out of his book physics book six
uh things being continuous
okay if their extremities are one
their extremities are one okay nothing
that is continuous can be composed of
indivisibles well i thought that
nothing that can be continuous can be
composed of anything
let alone indivisible should not be
composed of anything it should be made
of a single piece that's what continuous
means
example a line cannot be composed of
points that's what
aristotle said line is not made of
points according to him okay
but let's wait he's not finished yet
uh the line being continuous and the
point
indivisible so he's saying that
the line cannot be composed of points
because points are indivisible
and that which is continuous cannot be
made of stuff that
is indivisible it has to be divisible
you should be able to chop it and if the
point which is that which has no
part cannot be divided it's indivisible
then it cannot form part of a continuous
structure
so now he's contradicting himself
because he gives us the notion that can
the line is continuous because it's not
made of points because the point is
indivisible and it's got to be divisible
in order to be part of a something that
is continuous which is the line
and then he says but but he's telling us
that
it can't be made of a point only because
the point is
indivisible okay keep that in mind okay
but it's
the line is gonna be made of something
but it's not of
uh that which is indivisible that's
that's
what he's trying to say here okay since
indivisibles have no part they must be
in contact with one another as
whole with whole right he's saying if
you got two
apples they got to be in contact with
each other but you can should be able to
chop the
apple in half if you cannot chop the
apple in half
in this case the point because it has no
volume
no dimensions no nothing okay you can't
chop that which is nothing in half
okay then he's saying they could come
together if they
if if they were divisible but since
they're indivisible you they can't come
together
but this is how he ends up his analysis
if they are in contact with one another
they will not be continuous for that
which is continuous has what
distinct parts so what has
he chased his tail completely around he
says that which is continues
is made of distinct parts what parts
is a line made of if not
points if not these locations these
events so he says uh that which is
continuous
it has distinct parts so he starts out
by saying that continuous has to be made
of a single piece essentially he can't
it can't be made of points
but then he ends saying it has to be
made of distinct parts
and i don't know what else it could be
made of if other than points
that's the only other geometry which is
smaller or
or more basic than the line
what has aristotle said and just in case
you say well bill you
misinterpret it okay i always get
accused of
being misinterpreting everything reading
everything wrong okay
just the story of my life so here's mr
hawking stephen gawking he's going to
tell us
what aristotle said in his own words
here he says
aristotle believe that's us also out of
brief history of time
believe that matter was what continuous
okay that is one could divide a piece of
matter
into smaller and smaller bits without
any
limit one never came up
against a grain of matter that could not
be divided further
so yeah that is what aristotle says that
continuous is something you can chop
into pieces
well i thought that was what is not
continuous that's the opposite of
continuous
that's uh segmented if you can chop it
it's segmented made up pieces
so all these people have all these
notions completely
bunken yeah they're all nonsense all the
all the terms defined in geometry are
nonsense all of them
and so we don't have really a rational
geometry
and you might say well bill we've got
this far with all these geometry
geometric figures and definitions and
look at all the
stuff we invented and blah blah blah
because of geometry
we ended up with space time which is a
geometric uh
theory of
uh gravity of macro gravity out there
so you better pay attention because it's
because
of geometry that we have space time that
we ended up with all this mathematical
nonsense
that we ended up with a black hole which
is zero dimensional
and they call it an object they think
it's a thing it's a figure it's a it's a
whatchamacallit no if it's zero
dimensional because the
star that made that black hole collapsed
to zero size zero volume
like mr chandrasekhar said and got a
noble for saying that
for coming up with equations showing
that a black hole collapses to what
zero size we have nothing absolutely
nothing in front of us and they say well
it's
got infinite mass because you've got all
this mass and it's in
zero volume so that's approaching
infinite mass well that's all nonsense
uh infinite density i'm sorry uh that's
all nonsense
uh we're talking about physics we want
to know what physical object is in there
and if they say it's zero dimensional
zero size no radius no diameter
then we're not talking about an object
we're talking about nothing
there's no difference between space
which is nothing
and what you just described as a black
hole where did they get all this stuff
from geometry so yeah i do attack
geometry and i call it a religion
because it ended up with general
relativity
and it also with quantum mechanics and
now what do you think string theory is
doing
the same thing they're using gm geometry
what are they using are they using what
are these strings are they uh strings
like
this is a string you know like this one
that i showed a minute ago is that
is that what it is
there we go is that what string
and string theory is absolutely not
they're talking about
lines what is a line lines a bunch of
locations what is a bunch of locations
an itinerary that's what string theory
is they should call it itinerary
theories so that you don't get misled
see every time these people talk about
strings
people say oh i know what that is i know
what a string is
no that's not what these people are
talking about they're talking about
itineraries
closed-loop itineraries which they claim
that because
these closed-loop itineraries locations
vibrate they form particles so the
particles are made of locations
that are vibrating okay you got that
i hope you can take that with you to the
bank okay
okay so uh i think i have one more
yeah just wanted to show you this uh all
these people like
uh hawking and uh
niels bohr and uh feynman uh
einstein all these they followed uh
aristotle
uh if anything they modified aristotle a
little bit here and there just made it
worse
but they all essentially learned their
geometry from
aristotle and so here's a synthesis of
that
okay here's uh all the mathematicians
are blind and they're following a blind
man okay
that's what happened all we have is the
blind following the blind
and the or the blind leading the blind
okay so let's go with my conclusions
okay here it is
uh geometers since the days of the
greeks right
uh aristotle plato all these
great misconceived all geometric figures
all of them especially especially the
planes and below like line and
and the point because you know
none of them are objects none of them
are figures
what they are is motion they're
locations that's all they are
and location is not a geometric figure
because mr uh aristotle defined these
guys don't define it today but mr
aristotle defined figure as
that which has shaved that which has a
boundary okay
and this is not what they're talking
about at all they're talking about
locations and motion
geometry has never been the study of
shapes
never mathematicians have no use
for shapes they have no use for the
circle the real
honest-to-goodness circle here i'll show
you side-by-side won't blindside you
blind you uh this is a circle
and i mean well it's a three dimensional
circle it's got some width but you know
what i'm talking about
the point is mathematicians have no use
for this for a circle
they have no use for squares they have
no use for semicircles they have no use
for triangles they have no use for any
of these
figures what are they going to do with
it no what they want to look at is
relations they want to look at angles
they want to use the size
dimensions of of something you know
that's what they're looking at they're
not looking at the figure itself they
don't care about the figure
they're just going to put a dotted line
and say well this is how much i measured
they're going to represent that with a
line what is the line is just the
the unrolling of the measuring tape
that's all it is
mathematics has no use for shapes okay
geometry deals exclusively with motion
geometry meaning what these people do
okay they only deal with motion
geometry has always analyzed compared
dynamic relations
in other words measurements geometry is
the vain attempt
to merge mathematics and physics
math is math physics is physics never
the twain shall meet
and so you know
math cannot help physics at all physics
is about explaining a mechanism
we don't need any math whatsoever at
all we have no use whatsoever for math i
mean you can
uh describe with math fine you know you
want to say well what is the
acceleration of gravity you see 9.8
meters per second square here on
earth fine that's a description
you haven't done physics yet all you've
done is math all you said is yeah
there's
this is the acceleration that's a number
what is the speed of light three hundred
thousand kilometers per second what is
that
did you explain anything with that no
that's just a measurement
that's just a number you have not that's
a description you haven't you haven't
uh explained anything with that yet the
fact that you
in physics we say it much swifter we say
light is fast now how's that for
uh accuracy and precision it's fast
that's all we need to know it's fast now
we now please tell us what light is
and why it does the slit experiment and
why it does you know polarization that's
what we want to understand
but to tell me that light is fast and
that what a photon can be at two places
at once
well we don't care about those kinds of
explanation but those are the
explanation what who gives those
explanations mathematicians geometers
these mathematical physics
so-called physicists geometry there you
have it divided into
mathematics which is relations and
physics
which are the figures and what uh the
greeks try to do is
blend them together and you can't blend
mathematics with
physics one has nothing at all to do
with them with the other
okay so this is my conclusion on that
okay why don't we get into some of the
questions
uh comments have people made and again a
lot of it has to do with
um with understanding what physics is
about
and uh some of these people have no idea
what physics is about they
and all they want to do is preserve
their religions
and so i ask them look an object is that
which has shape
and i justify it i'm saying that's the
only
like i did before that's the only
property all objects have
universally etc etc cetera and i i
justify each statement and they say well
no you're wrong bill
that's not what an object is okay what
is an object
in the alternative for the purposes of
physics
and so this uh the main one is c touch
and yeah of course they can't defend c
touch and so they never do defend c
touch the only defense they have is
it's tradition we learned it from
authority we i i memorized it when i was
at the monastery
okay great uh but you can't defend that
you can't defend the sea
and touch because you can't see the air
and the air is made out of atoms and the
atoms hopefully are objects so you what
do you have
uh air is not an object even though it's
made out of
atoms it's a something that blew your
house
away you know the tornado and uh
all that air was nothing so you know uh
you got to define what an object is you
got to define what a concept is
you gotta you can't say a concept blew
your house away
not in physics maybe outside in you know
in uh
in ordinary speech you can say that you
can say love move mountains
you can't use that terminology in
physics
physics you got to have a physical
object if you want to move in a mountain
okay and that's the way it works
okay and so uh one file says
pointing with a finger always imply the
human senses
my god what do you got to tell this
poor fellow i mean
he's completely out of it doesn't have a
notion of what we're talking about
when we say observer we're talking about
theories okay
and pointing is not the definition of an
object
what we're saying is that an object is
that which you point to
if you're going to teach the word tree
or the word square to
a an et someone who doesn't know your
language you say
tree and you point is that observer well
if we die
is the tree still there the tree stands
alone without me the fact that i pointed
just to name it
just so the guy understands the language
what problem do you have you got a
mental problem
you know you really is some of these
people really have you know
uh something so simple that they cannot
really understand it's
for me it's mind-blowing that they
cannot understand something so
straightforward so simple
okay uh another fella
[Music]
tries to analyze me okay i need a psycho
analysis okay what does this guy say he
says
uh religion assume there's a god
mechanism of world creation equal god
did it and conclusion i believe
god created our world okay that's what
he thinks religion is
okay and then he says this is how bill
does it in with a rope model he says
assume there's a thread
mechanism of world creation have no idea
where he got that at all i don't use
creation at all
thread intertwines to give a rope with a
thread having two different properties
don't ask how
and that leads to objects in the
universe
that lead that lead that lead and that
lead to
objects in the universe and conclusion
believe in my model i am god's
uh prophet he didn't even obviously he's
not a very uh educated guy he misspelled
prophet prophet on earth who cannot be
questioned by
experimentation or any other scientific
process
well experimentation is not a scientific
process it has nothing to do
with science because the only purpose of
experiments are to persuade and convince
the jury
and we don't do that in science that's
why
we don't believe or you know he he's
putting words in my mouth
so let's put the bill version here okay
this is the real person so that
people understand what i propose
compared to what this
bean brain here uh put out there which
is nonsense he just
uh he's just upset that
he has no arguments okay and that's why
he's he's got to say something that's
the nonsense he said
no this is the bill the real bill okay
here um
assumptions assume there's a pair of
twine threads a rope which i'm pointing
to okay i point to the rope here i even
this this is what i'm saying two twine
threads a rope
uh any questions of what i'm talking
about i'm talking about a rope
twine threads looks like dna i don't
know
how else to if you don't understand what
i just by showing you tell you what
you're staring at i don't know how else
to present it
but this fellow apparently you know has
a mental block he doesn't know what a
rope is or he doesn't know what i'm
talking about
so i don't know i'll show it here i drew
it okay i don't know how else to present
it so he understands what a rope is
okay okay and uh assume the atom is a
ball made of these same threads there
you see it on the bottom uh three
dimensional on the right
uh two dimensional on the left okay i'm
pointing to all atoms are interconnected
i'm not sure what people would not
understand about that
what part do you not understand so far
is this over your head i mean
maybe this guy has a you know mental
capacity of
a two-year-old i don't know maybe he's
autistic
all kinds of people out there i mean
what part don't you understand about
this
i'm saying that there's two threads
they're twined
okay and they fork out at the
boundary of the electron shell okay they
can move around they form the atom
which when it expands and contracts
torques the rope
that's what is what i'm saying here what
part of that don't you understand
even before that i mean just don't you
understand uh what i'm saying
we have two balls and they're connected
by a rope
i mean i don't know what else to do to
have you
understand my assumption
because look at look at what he said
again i mean
this is what this file says he says
thread intertwines to give a rope with a
thread having two different properties i
don't know why he talks
uh properties we're not there yet we're
just trying to understand what what i'm
presenting i'm saying that
there's two threads two twenty threads
and that leads to objects in the
universe and there leads to objects to
the atoms
and he doesn't understand that he
doesn't comprehend
something as simple as that okay let's
look at the mechanism now he talks about
a mechanism of creation i'm not sure
where he got that
obviously you know he's he's talking
about some other site not this one
induced by the tug of all atoms in
existence our atom expands and contracts
okay so here we have a little atom okay
it expands and contracts
i just want you to understand the
mechanism i don't want you to believe in
it i don't want you to criticize it yet
just want you to understand it
right now we're talking about
understanding right now this fellow
doesn't have a mental capacity to
understand this this is what's
incredible
by doing so it torques the rope so here
you have this thing that's made out of
the same threads
when it expands it torques the rope the
torsion moves along you know the rope
what part of that he cannot understand
is just beyond me okay torsion
propagates along the rope to the next
atom
and stimulates it to expand and contract
as well so
by expanding here torques the robin
triggers the other atom to
do the same so if this one's doing it
faster it will
trigger the other one to do it faster as
well torsion along the rope is what we
call
light and the thump that the atom
comprising our eyes
receives is how we detect light
that's the mechanism that's that's the
theory that i'm presenting what part did
you not
understand i mean right now we're
talking about understanding
i don't care if you believe in it that
doesn't enter the picture
i just need to know if you understood it
and right now this this
person is individual he doesn't
understand this he's got a mental
problem
he says he's a teacher i don't know who
he teaches maybe [ __ ] children at a
mental asylum i don't know who he
teaches what could he teach where can he
possibly teach
he can't understand this and i think
this is baby stuff i think a 10 year old
can understand this
okay and
so he continues oh no well this is my
conclusion on that
okay and it goes like this these are the
conclusions
for um for the rope
we have now illustrated a mechanism of
how light propagates
along a physical mediator hopefully
light is mediated by a physical object
because you can't do physics without an
object so you need an object in there
otherwise you're doing magic you're
doing spirits
so there better be an object that
mediates light
let's get that straight okay and quantum
does it with particles but their
particles are not particles
so quantum doesn't count uh relativity
also uses the same uh they say it's
photons what are photons well
numbers that's what they are they move
numbers around
so uh and the the people who
who propose ether which are usually the
dissidents
what they're using is particles but they
use real core puzzles
and they have these corpuscles moving up
and down waving they say that's light
so uh yeah that doesn't work either
because you got to explain why
the particle goes up and where it goes
down what what
what forms that wave
uh in the ether that's what you got to
explain does a
particle pull on the other particle when
they go up in the sine
wave you know it has that shiny wavy
thingy right so one particle pulls on
the other one why would it go up in the
first place
okay so are they tied together all these
particles all these ether particles
so these are the issues that an etherist
cannot explain a guy who does it with
real core puzzles
and quantum does it without corpus so
they just use numbers
they don't use physical objects at all
that's why it's not part of physics
okay and so you know again
that's the uh i've illustrated the
mechanism so that you understand it
okay so that you comprehend it what part
you don't understand is
means that you have the mentality of a
five-year-old or less
maybe that's why you don't understand it
what part can
can't you understand of how light
propagates
uh you know along a rope when i'm saying
it's a torsion that moves along the rope
what part i mean here let me illustrate
this is light you know see if i can
torque it in
i can't target at the speed of light but
that's what i'm saying that's what it is
what part don't you understand about
that
that's all i want to know what part
don't you understand not that you
believe
i just want you to understand the
mechanism and right now these people
can't understand the mechanism
okay along a physical mediator that is
also the mediator
of action at a distance phenomena such
as gravity so this one not only
uh does light propagate through the rope
but the ropes
all the ropes from because all atoms are
interconnected those are what are going
to
uh produce gravity okay okay
religion uh again whether you believe in
the objective mechanism just illustrated
is of no concern to science
so we don't care about your belief okay
and there is no experiment you can run
okay an experiment cannot tell us
anything about an invisible intangible
entity such as the mediator of light
here's light you know uh and i can pass
my hand i don't touch light
okay so i can't touch or see it does
that mean that there's no object there
that mediates light
is that what you're saying you're saying
that's done with spirits
when when we shine our laser to the moon
to the
uh lunar ranger experiment right to the
to this uh
mirror that we put on the moon we shine
a laser
what's going through space nothing just
a ghost hopefully you've got something
going you know from the laser pointer
to the mirror hopefully there's
something in between there
and what you got to tell me is what
mediates light
what is the mediator of light if you
can't tell me that you know get out of
physics stay with religion
don't tell me that there's nothing there
there is something there we can't see it
or touch it but there's something that
mediates light
and for hundreds of years they use the
particle then they gave up on a
corpuscle it's called a corpuscle the
classical
particle and then they went into quantum
mechanics they say we forgot about
you know completely about the objects we
don't care about that anymore we're just
going to describe it mathematically
and of course they use the photon but
the photon is just a number
and you know that's how they came up
with virtual photons they can create
them out of
you know the mathematical mind they just
create them
to fill the equation that's very easy
and the only purpose of an experiment is
evidence okay
that's the only reason people do
experiments is for evidence
not for in other words it attacks belief
opinion it doesn't it doesn't explain
anything objectively
explain you have to explain it
separately the experiment's not an
explanation the experiment
you know here's an experiment uh i let
go of the pen
okay and it falls down to the floor
okay there's the experiment you want me
to do it a million times so it's
repeatable and it's
scientific fine i'll do it a million
times now please explain to me
why what caused it to fall that's what
you got to tell me
doing experiments will not tell us
anything they've been doing experiments
on gravity
for who knows how long and no one can
tell you what gravity is in fact quantum
doesn't even have
the graviton yet doesn't have the
particle of gravity in its
standard model and they've done all
kinds of experiments what
what other experiments do you need to
run in order to
tell me you know how the graviton does
it how are you gonna explain that
with a graviton you can't you can't
explain with particles
okay gravity is a tug of some kind
you know it's the the pen is somehow
pulled
towards the earth to the center of the
earth and you got to tell me what the
mediator
of gravity is before you even tell me
your theory
because otherwise you're going to be
doing magic black magic if you don't put
a mediator there
physics is done with objects you can't
do physics without object you need an
object for gravity you need an
object for light you need an object for
electricity and you need an object for
magnetism
for all the stuff you can't do without
objects
and that's what these people don't
understand they want to do without
objects
and they say well not just that which
you can see and touch why because that's
what they do
with experiments and experiments cannot
tell us anything
about invisible intangible mediators
and if you don't put a mediator and do
it with spirits
okay so that's the logic behind that
and no we don't care about authority we
don't care how many mathematicians voted
for
a given theory plays no role whatsoever
in science
okay
here's a continuation to that
this is what mathematical physics really
does
and this is what this fellow did not
really address what mathematical physics
does
and here it is they assume assume there
are particles
which ain't particles but rather
equations let's call them fields or
waves or energy or there's just
virtual particles to mislead and confuse
the gulliple
idiots who know nothing about math and
swallow this stuff like candy on the
basis of our authority
we'll just brush aside challenges of
skeptics saying that
physical interpretations belong in what
in philosophy
mechanism of how two real photons morph
into two virtual photons as we had the
other day and it goes like this more or
less
the photon particle we change that
particle okay splits into a negative
electron particle which ain't a particle
and a positive position
positron particle which also ain't a
particle we have no clue what negative
and positive mean in physical terms but
let's roll along since the gullible
idiots never ask
i mean when is it this fellow ask what
does negative and positive mean
what is it in physical terms that's what
we need to find out we need to
find out why negative attracts a
positive not just stated and say well x
attracts y
yeah but you need to tell me why what
causes x
to attract y you can't tell me what
causes it what do you what does it
matter if you name one x and the other
one y
the positron virtual field bangs against
the electron virtual
energy both of which popped out of the
vacuum through a
mechanism that we will explain in our
lecture
scheduled for the year 3001 and the wave
function collapses into photon balls
which ain't balls but rather equations
or points
or ether or something like that this is
what these people say this
this is their explanations uh
explanation in this case for how a
photon morphs into two virtual photons
they go through this whole rigamarole
and and they do experiments they did a
hundred experiments on this
and they came up with this nonsense they
come up with virtual photons what else
can they come up with
and so and this guy believes all this
stuff on the basis of authority only
because they say oh those scientists the
scientists
scientists my foot you know these people
are not scientists anyone who talks
about virtual particles is a religious
idiot
that's how he should be treated that's
the correct word i'm sorry
i got to treat them with the respect
that they deserve don't tell me a
particle can be at two places at once
don't tell me that
virtual particles pop in from the void
and then they go back and recombine
negative with positive
especially if you don't know what
negative and positive mean okay
so yeah it's all these people who just
swallow this stuff but
like candy they they have no ability to
think
beyond what uh the authorities tell them
to believe
and they just believe in they say well
but they're running experiments and look
at all those equations
who understands all that thank god they
understand it
again you can sell them the empire state
building twice
okay the important part is that we
proved experimentally this is how they
would end their
conclusions right this this is how they
usually talk
uh through direct observation of the
photon balls direct observations of the
photons
see they use that word observation these
people are so gullible they
they accept it what do you mean
observation you mean like with your eyes
is that what you meant by observation
why do they use the word observation
because it insinuates that they have
proof that they sought with their own
eyes that's why they use the word
observation they have all these
uh you know words out there that they've
created
these uh what's the word i'm looking for
these uh misleading terms
that they use out there okay in the lab
through direct observation
of the photon balls which ain't balls
that two photon balls
morph into a virtual fields or energy or
wave or functions and back again
you should believe our findings why
because we've got
jobs and you don't our gold medals given
to us
by our peers prove it okay and what do
you have
how many of our peers voted for your
skepticism
that's essentially what they're telling
you all these so-called mathematical
physicist they call
themselves scientists nevertheless you
wouldn't have that computer you're
typing on if it weren't for
that our theory is correct they think
that technology proves there that a
particle can be at two places at once
that's that's the date that's what we
have from mathematical physics today and
these people
just swallow it i mean they have no
problem swallowing this stuff and you
tell them look
try to open your eyes you're hypnotized
you're believing all this stuff that a
particle can be at two places once
yeah they proved it with an experiment
see
science is about running experiments
well here they ran experiments this is
the nonsense they came up with that a
particle can be at two places at once
and these people actually believe this
stuff they they believe a particular two
places at once and that
the star collapsed into a black hole and
they said yeah it's a zero dimensional
nothing and it swallows other stars
swallows matter
okay okay and this guy uh
makes another comment another criticism
there
okay good let him come says fields
what is the field are numbers or vectors
yeah
numbers and direction but they represent
actual physical things
uh like what please tell me
what physical thing please tell me what
a thing is first but then
what physical things do fields represent
don't just leave us there hanging you
know
from a cliff tell us exactly
draw it what does the field
represent what physical thing
what is a physical thing
and it turns out that he gives a couple
references videos on what a field
is what what is a field okay fine
we can get to a field let's find out
what a field is
well the first guy he references is this
fellow
nick lucid which i talked about a little
while ago
and this doesn't have the slightest clue
what physics is about
uh he looks like curly i call him curly
okay
i shaved his head or whatever and um
and this is what uh good old nick says
okay he has this
he starts out by saying he has this y
and x axis i don't know why he needs
that
at all but here's the real the key issue
what are those little numbers that you
see there are those little things
i don't know if you can see them well so
let me expand them
that's what they are they're numbers
a field is a bunch of numbers
so this fellow says that they represent
real things well
i don't know what real thing is because
everybody puts numbers whenever they
talk about a field
in fact the field is a bunch of numbers
that's all it is
and here we have another fella that he
referenced the other fella here
and this fella uh his name is ed
reena irene and what does this guy
say well he says a field is a region
what is the region of physical object is
that the object the physical object that
this other fellow is talking about
a region a region of the hand is the
palm
so is the palm you know as as a region
of the hand is the problem
in that context is that a physical
object
no of course not a region is never a
physical standalone
object region is always of something
else
you know china is a region of the planet
okay
it's got to be of something else so if a
field is a region
obviously it's not a standalone object
cannot be confused for a thing
you got to tell me what thing what
physical object as he said there uh
it represents hopefully he'll answer the
question
uh more than likely he'll run away and
just give us more run around he'll say
well it's a bunch of numbers
yeah and if they represent a physical
thing just tell me the physical thing it
represents
and you got to tell me what a physical
thing is okay
you got to define that term because the
definition of the word thing
destroys your religion okay you got to
tell me what thing is
what that thing is that makes up a field
or what the field represents
okay and
so we look up uh this file he says
[Music]
he says the weird nature of quantum
mechanics
weird nature why does he use the word
weird well that's because that's the
word that
all the authorities that he listens to
use the word
weird they say quantum is weird
quantum is irrational only idiots
believe in quantum let's say like it is
don't say
weird say irrational say idiotic
why do you use the word weird like see
it's strange
no it's not strange it's idiotic the
explanation is idiotic it's
irrational don't say weird when you mean
irrational and idiotic
don't confuse those terms okay this is
where the problem is people say well
it's weird my god here are some videos
which help us explain
some of the issues okay i want to
explain just one issue let's find out
these people don't make up hypothesis
meaning me
right that are inconsistent with
observations and experimentation
okay tell me what observation tells us
that there's something called a wave
packet
the hypothesis known as the wave package
how about a
particle which ain't a particle because
the particle is not
the classical corpuscle how about
how can a particle be at two places at
once uh is that what they proved with
experiments
how did they prove that a particle can
be in two places at once
or please draw an h atom i mean uh
you're saying it's consistent with
experiment
okay just draw an h atom what are you
going to draw a little bead rolling
around a
little booming ball in the center
so don't tell me that uh hypothesis must
be consistent with observation
experimentation
not one of uh not one
of quantum mechanics um observation
experiments matches the nonsense that
quantum proposes and has been proposing
for over a hundred years now
so no it's not true and he
mentioned some uh some people there some
references
and yeah i gotta laugh at all these
people one is sabine hassanfeld right
talked about her a couple weeks ago
i mean this lady doesn't have the
slightest clue about anything
about anything i mean she's not a
physicist she's a mathematician
she does a lot of equations and has no
idea whatsoever
about anything related to physics and
here's a proof
evidence okay let's show some evidence
proof let's convince people which is
what the mathematicians do okay here it
is let's convince people
what does this lady talk about well she
says she's got a site
on youtube says science without the
goblin group okay let's find out if
that's true
and she has a video one of them because
this is her main topic the one she
works on with her group here in germany
in fact she uh she works a
couple miles here in north where i live
and she says
are dark energy and dark matter
scientific and i
highlighted that area says dark energy
and dark matter are entirely normal
and perfectly scientific hypothesis
and there you see what dark energy is
it's that all that smoke
that's pushing all the galaxies apart so
this is what she studies this is what
her group
uh specifically does every day this is
her
bread and butter okay so she believes in
dark
energy and what is dark energy well dark
energy is the
there was an initial explosion called
the big bang
and everything's moving farther and
farther away from each other according
to some of these
so-called mathematical physicists and
so they say everything's moving out and
that's because of the big bang and then
the question is why doesn't gravity pull
everything inwards again
well they say it's all this dark energy
that's pushing everything out
okay so what is dark energy i mean
who is it feynman says no one has the
slightest clue what energy is
but now they invented dark energy now
they found out it's dark
so what is this dark energy what
physical object
is it if it's pushing all galaxies away
i mean if it's pushing the earth
farther and farther away from whatever
then uh and the whole solar system for
that matter right
uh we're talking about something that's
coming up against the skin
of the earth the skin of the sun the
skin of jupiter
what is that something that's pushing us
or pushing all these galaxies apart and
all this stuff
you got to identify the object the thing
that's pushing us apart or is it a
spirit
is it uh you know should we call it
spirit
dark spirit maybe is that a better word
or is that too
religious sounding because that's what
they're saying they're saying it's
magical
it's something that's not there it's
some kind of
energy whatever that is that's pushing
us all apart
and that's what this lady studies what
can she know about
physics what can this lady know about
physics physics
is about explaining mechanism these
people cannot explain
who their fathers were
okay here's the other fellow his name is
jim baggett
and another uh nonsense that
you'll read in his site what does this
guy say he says
well he says many things but i focused
on this one because it's so interesting
he says
but how does the electron go from being
almost
everywhere to being here you can see the
word here that's where the electron is
this is where it came out of and what
they can't figure out is what's in
between
the dragon he said the great smoky
dragon yeah that's the one we need to
identify
what is that physical object what
mediates transactions gravity
uh light magnetism we need to
identify the smoky dragons
has mr baggett done that does he know
what physical object is there no he just
ponders
there's got to be an object there but we
don't know what it is and that's the end
of the story and then continue doing
math and explaining everything with
nonsense with
irrationality now you got to identify
the object then it's completely
easy to understand then it's rational if
you don't identify the invisible objects
that would just shape right not that
which we can touch or see
then uh then yeah you're going to be
running around in circles like these
people have been doing for the last 400
years
at least okay and
here's the fermi lab the last group that
this fellow identified
site
and what does fermilab talk about well
they talk about several things but i
like this one because they talk about
uh the multiverse they say that every
time you take a step you branch off into
different universes
this is what fermilab tells the people
out there this is
one of the authorities that this
individual listens to and pays attention
called science he thinks this is science
it says the wave function predicts what
can happen when you collapse the wave
function great
you literally create several universes
in which each one of the possible
outcomes
occurs this is what they're teaching
the new generation they call this
science and this guy
swallows it like candy unbelievable he
thinks yeah it's a multiverse you know
we branch off into all these universes
they actually believe this stuff they
have no problem
and then they laugh at some of the other
people say oh he believes in god he
believes in spirit
what do you believe in you're believing
that you branch off into a million
universes
every time you take a step
unbelievable half of the world laughs at
the other half
okay and a final comment here by someone
fella says i can get this up here
uh bill rigid means single piece
that's me saying that he says no rigid
means unable to bend or be forced out of
shape not flexible
um oh man got so much to say about that
let's see if i can synthesize yes and no
we got both here uh when we talk about
rigidity in our macro world well we know
that
nothing is rigid not even a steel beam
is rigid
because you can send vibration through
it you can bang it and uh
you know your sound will move through it
so something's vibrating in there
okay so uh a steel beam as solid as it
is or
a concrete wall as solid as it seems
everything
is non-rigid because everything is made
out of parts
known as atoms and so nothing is rigid
okay in our macro world let's
let's get the context right here in our
macro world
it would have to be made of a single
piece
like if all the atoms somehow were fused
together into a single
like this guy said earlier there are uh
spaces between you know the dots and
he's saying no there ain't
everything's covered with dots let's
assume all the dots are fused and you
have a
you know a plate made of a single piece
somehow
imagine that you know like flowed and it
made a single piece
well if it's like that only then can you
talk about rigidity
in our macro world in
our macro world okay now
uh under the rope model we have a
strange situation
because uh you know the thread is
something that's unique
and we don't have any uh comparable
thing in our macro world
comparable to the thread the thread is
made
of a single piece but it is
flexible and everybody goes oh
that's where everybody goes nuts what do
you mean it's made of a single piece
that's flexible yeah
and in our macro world we have no uh
no analogy of that because everything is
made of pieces
of atoms and therefore we have no
rigidity and the only way we can imagine
rigidity
if it's made out of a single piece so
again yes and no you got to look at the
context
in order to answer that question okay
correctly so you
have you don't have to confuse the
definition you found in the dictionary
with what we have in under the rope
model we have a new situation here where
we have we're proposing
that we have a thread made of a single
piece which has the property of
flexibility
okay it's uh malleable
and all you got to do is uh
accept that in order to understand the
theory doesn't mean you have to believe
in it it's just
you you concede the assumption
in order to understand the theory that's
all there is whether you believe
that that's how the universe is in
reality
well that's known as religion we all
have our religions
i have mine you have yours you believe
in what you have to have believe in what
i have to believe
and with that i'll see you i'll see you
on sunday
bye bye